j'aime et j'ai téléphoné à quiconque
pour avoir dissous mais vous êtes
consciente que safran dissous pour ce
pays avait
la députée julie boulet devant la
commission charbonneau aujourd'hui elle
témoignait beaucoup à titre d'ancienne
ministre des transports dans le
gouvernement de jean charest à
témoignages qui était très attendu
isabelle et pour mieux le comprendre il
faut remonter à l'autre témoignages
marquants de cette semaine celui de
louis marchand week une entreprise avec
son papa qui viennent entreprises de par
âge exact et qui était dans la danse en
mauricie donc sur le territoire de
madame boulet et qui dit deux choses
importantes et c'est pour ça qu'on se
souvient de lui le financement populaire
c'est un mythe c'est une hypocrisie
totale et quand il a décidé de prendre
ses distances et de cesser de financer
les partis politiques l'un comme l'autre
mais là il avait cessé de financer le
parti libéral il dit qu'il n'a plus
jamais eu de contrôle tarifé à lorient
car soumissionner pour des appels
d'offres il n'y a plus eu de contre
tarifs et du gouvernement les contrats
tarifs et pour qu'on suive biens cédés
contre collomb donne sans appel d'offres
pour encourager les entreprises qui ont
pas les moyens de survie nuit qui sont
dans des régions où il n'ya pas de
concurrence là où ils sont éloignés
voilà alors on va écouter si vous le
voulez bien plusieurs minutes de ce
témoignage devant la boule et puis on
revient après pour l'analyse
jeunes et madame la présidente je mets
jamais fait de financement je n'ai
jamais vendu un seul billet pour un
cocktail pour nous peu importe
l'activité financement mais jamais vendu
une seule carte demande jamais j'ai
téléphoné à quiconque pour avoir dissous
j'ai jamais regarder non plus avant
d'aller un cocktail peu importe la liste
des gens qui avaient donné j'ai jamais
regarder comment ils donnaient et chevy
même pau-langevin que vos enquêteurs
viennent me voir comment d'argent été
ramassées chaque année à l'enjeu g je me
suis jamais occupé de financement
combien vous coûte et vos élections
mais si je sais pas si vous avez dit que
vous aviez de l'ag de l'épreuve où
beaucoup de rigueur oui que vous étiez à
quand céline et que vous surveillez mes
affaires mais vous savez pas combien
vous remercier mais vous savez pas
combien coûtait votre élection
madame la présidente j'ai un agent
officiel alors j le droit afin de leur
subconscient de l'an 75 par personne ont
pensé mais givry six hommes ça a diminué
cette fois ci c'était moins que les
élections précédentes alors faisait un
budget avec ce qu'ils avaient doivent
dépenser donc si je comprends bien oui
vous rappeler que dans des caucus vous
avez appris combien députés pouvaient
ceux ayant parlé de son objectif combien
dans le comté orphelins le côté devait
ramasser comme objectif la seule chose
que vous vous rappelez pas ce qu'on
vient des minutes elle avait peut-être
qu'il n'en parlait pas l'eau madame la
présidente gens nommés la seule chance
que vous vous rappelez pas certain que
ministre combien quel était votre
objectif sincèrement madame la
présidente laure ça peut vous sembler je
ne savais pas ce que je comprends que
vous n'avez demande jamais demandé à
personne de cesser d'octroyer de
tarifaires mais j'ai jamais demandé
jamais jamais jamais demandé à qui que
ce soit de nuire ou de ne pas donner de
contrôle est un esquimau masci bon on va
finir par la faim maskimo donc cette
entreprise de louis marchand lui prétend
qu tout cas l'avis a été plus dur pour
son entreprise depuis qu'il ne donnait
plus à madame boulet oui absolument il
avait même dit que madame bull il avait
appelé parce qu'elles étaient très déçus
qui participa en 2004 à un cocktail de
financement et le nuit avoir insisté
auprès de lui pour qu'il vienne a dit
avait parfaitement le droit de pau mais
hélas il ya en tout cas une tentative
claire de prendre dans son cas c'est
distance mais le wind loin possible de
tout ce qui y est financement du parti
libéral du québec comme si c'était
quelque chose que je ne regarde jamais
c'est comme c'était sale c'est ça qui
est un peu étrange comme façon de
se comporter à la même dit je trouvais
ça un peu répugnant je veux pas dire ce
monde là parce qu'évidemment le stop
fort mais elle il y avait quelqu'un qui
s'occupaient de ça dans mon comté
aminata fille qui était un membre de son
personnel dans son comté et cette
personne s'occupait de faire du
financement pour moi et je voulais pas
le savoir mais quand on l'interrogeait
davantage là elle savait combien y avait
des billets de vendus parce qu'après
tout on voulait savoir si l'événement
allait fonctionner et est capable de
multiplier donc je savais que ça faisait
un montant x ou y alors est-ce elle n'en
faisait pas mais elle s'y intéresser
mélodie ce n'est que lorsque vos
enquêteurs de la commission sont venus
voir que j'ai appris combien d'argent on
avait recueilli et donc je re souligne
cet élément de la commission a posé
beaucoup beaucoup de questions sur ce
lien là entre l'absence de financement
d'une entreprise de pavage et l'absence
de contre on veut faire s'est passé ça
le gaz la commission et voilà c'est le
lien que la commission souhaite établir
qui a été établi par un certain nombre
de témoins maintenant qu'on au long de
côté c'est à dire les élus aux
transports a fortiori mais là c'est sûr
qu'on essaie de d'attaché leafs elle
madame boulet dit que non qu'il n'y en a
aucun lien il ya des témoins qui ont dit
le contraire on verra bien c'est quoi
les conclusions il le sera la commission
de départager donc la crédibilité de
tous et isabelle merci beaucoup